well it's 2016 August 2016 summer day in
LA we know why I felt they needed to say
that but we work but we met with you the
first time in 2012 which and that was
about four years ago so since that time
a lot has happened in your life you've
been in part of projects different
things have you become more idealistic
about filmmaking less so more realistic
about what is needed to work in
Hollywood have you had any kind of great
question have you talked to people that
get more idealistic as their career go
down that I always talk about it because
it's an interesting question because
after we last met i think i was just in
preparation for a movie I think I was
just about to shoot turkington which is
my last feature film I haven't made a
feature film since then and such a thing
you're asking whether I got more
idealistic or or or less I think it's a
mixture of both because I'm very proud
of 13 cents but it never went anywhere
made nine thousand dollars at the box
office and it came after last exorcism
which was this you can discuss whether
that's a better film or worse film or
whatever but box-office wife it was a 70
million dollar success going to a nine
thousand dollar complete failure at the
box office right which I would claim I
have nothing to do with either not with
that success and not with that failure
because it's marketing and how much
money is being pumped into stuff last
exorcism had a marketing budget of 24
million dollars so it's easier of course
to get people to see it and to make that
kind of money 13 since didn't have a
single dollar of marketing budget and
that depended on without pointing
fingers but it depends on who buys your
movie of course and that in that case
the company that bought the movie just
before 13 since was going to be released
had a huge flop with a movie that they
had big hopes for and had done a big
marketing campaign for and they were
just out of money they did not have the
capacity of getting 13 since released
theatrically you know so suddenly you
are a VOD movie which is not a problem
but it is it
of course in if you see the chart of
your career the way it's perceived
you're going from you know the worldwide
theatrical moving to the VOD movie in
America which means that nowhere else in
the world it's going to go theatrical so
suddenly you have a movie that is you
know basically disappearing which has
nothing to do with its quality just as
this success didn't necessarily have
anything to do with its quality you know
but of course you are being held
accountable so I then kind of had to see
where to get my next paycheck from
because suddenly I am NOT this film noir
cat maker anymore cuz Hollywood as
always your worth as much as your last
project made at the box office basically
so I was worth this much of the last
exorcism and it was worth this much
after 13th in which is a real problem to
get yourself out of so the answer is TV
you know and I was always like I don't
want to do TV I don't do TV but a I had
to get my rent check from somewhere and
be I think a landscape really changed
maybe I'm just telling myself that's
because now I'm doing to me but I think
a lot has happened since we last spoke
in terms of TV was true detective with
Game of Thrones but some of the best
storytelling to that today is being done
in TV but not actually as bleak a world
as I would have thought that gland that
TV is
you